conservatives are now shocked that the
left has redefined male and female which
is perplexing to me because why would
that be shocking when they redefine man
and woman why would you think they
redefine those words but they're not
going to redefine male and female and
strip them all meaning well of course
they were going to you can't like
retreat into that linguistic territory
we and expect them not to muddle that up
either and we had uh lands from the
serfs the leftist
I said someone asked what is a woman and
he says easy an adult human female and I
said oh okay so trans women are not
women he goes no they are trans women
are female he said yeah I'm just
thinking about Lance that makes no sense
I explained to him that men that
transition to be trans women are trans
women and men at the same time they
don't stop being one to become the other
they become both and he was like no
that's not what they think but but I
think he was telling me like what the
current brainwashing is is that they
don't but the reality is you never stop
being human when you become a trans man
or a trans woman you're still a human
you're still a man and now you're a
trans woman and a man